in the last video we figured out that if
we had a proton
coming in to the right at a velocity of
six times ten to the seventh meters per
second so the magnitude of the velocity
is one-fifth the speed of light and if
it were to cross this magnetic field we
used this formula to figure out that the
magnitude of the force on this protein
proton not protein would be 4.8 times 10
to the negative 12 newtons and the
direction we used our right hand rule
because this is a cross product and we
figured out that it would be
perpendicular well has to be
perpendicular to both because we're
taking the cross product and right when
it enters the net force will be
downwards but then as think about what
happens if you have a downward force
right there then the product will be
deflected downward a little bit so it's
velocity vector will then look something
like that but it's still in the magnetic
field right and not only is it still in
the magnetic field but since the
particle is still moving within the
plane of your
video screen it's still completely
perpendicular to the magnetic field and
so the ch the the magnitude of the force
on the moving particle won't change just
the direction will right because the if
we do the right hand rule here but if we
just move our hand
down a little bit if we tilt it down
then our thumb is going to be pointing
in this direction
and that just keeps happening gets
deflected that way a little bit so the
magnitude of the velocity doesn't ever
change it always stays perpendicular to
the magnetic field because it's always
staying in this plane but the
orientation does change within the plane
and because of that because the
orientation velocity changes the
orientation of the force changes so when
the velocity is here the force is
perpendicular so it acts as kind of a
centripetal force and so the particle
will start moving in a circle
so let's see if we can break out our
tool kit from what we've learned before
in classical mechanics and figure out
what the radius of that circle is and
that might seem more daunting than it
really is well what do we know about
centripetal forces and radiuses of
circles etc let me make some space first
see i probably don't need this
i don't even need the first few of these
field lines
let's see well i'll leave everything
else i'll get rid of that field line
that should give us enough space
i'll try to write small but
legibly
so what is the formula for centripetal
force and we prove it many many videos
ago early in the physics playlist well
centripetal acceleration is
the magnitude of the velocity vector
squared over the radius of the circle
and since this is acceleration if we
want to know the centripetal force it's
just the mass times acceleration so it's
the mass of the particle or the object
in question times the magnitude of its
velocity squared divided by the radius
and circle in this case this is the
radius of the circle
and that's what we're going to try to
solve for
and what do we know about the
centripetal force what is causing the
centripetal force what's the magnetic
field and we figure that out
right this is going to be equal to this
which we figured out is going to be
equal to
at least the magnitudes the magnitude of
this is equal to the magnitude of this
and that the magnitude is 4.8
times 10 to the minus
12. newtons
and so
the radius is going to be let's see if
we
flip both sides of this equation
we get
radius
over mass
velocity squared is equal to 1 over 4.8
times 10 to the minus 12.
i could just figure out what that number
is but i won't worry that right now then
we can multiply both sides
this
times this mv squared and we get that
the radius
of this circle is going to be equal to
the mass
of the proton
times its the magnitude of its velocity
squared
the magnitude of its velocity squared
divided by
the force
from the magnetic field the centripetal
force
4.8 times 10 to the minus 12
newtons and the radius should be in
meters since everything is kind of in
the standard si units and let's see if
we can
figure this out
get our calculator and this is where
that constant function is useful again
because what is the mass of a proton
well that's something that i personally
don't have memorized but if we go into
the built-in constants on the ti-85
let's see more
mass of a proton this is mass of an
electro let me scoot it over a little
bit this is mass of an electron this is
mass of a proton so mass of a proton
that's what we care about
times the magnitude of the velocity
squared what was the velocity it was six
times 10 to the seventh meters per
second
so
times six times ten
to the seventh meters per second
squared
right because i have to take them and
then all of that divided by
all that divided by
the magnitude of the centripetal force
which is the force that's being
generated by the magnetic field that's
4.8 times 10 to the negative 12
so divided by 4.8
e minus 12.
let's see hopefully we don't get
something funky
there we go and that's actually a pretty
neat number 1.25
meters that's actually kind of a
number that we can imagine
so if you have a
a proton going through and going in this
direction at six at one fifth the speed
of light through a what did i say it was
it was a 0.5 tesla magnetic field where
the vectors are pointing out of the
video
we have just shown that this proton will
go in a circle of radius 1.25 meters
which is neat because it's a number that
i can actually visualize
and so this this whole business of
magnetic fields making torch particles
go into circles this is one of the few
times that i can actually say has a
direct application into some things into
things that you've seen namely your tv
or at least the the old school tvs and
the non-uh plasma or lcd tvs your
cathode ray tvs take advantage of this
where you essentially have a beam of not
protons but electrons
and a magnet if you take apart tv which
i don't think you should do because
you're more likely to hurt yourself
because there's a vacuum in there that
can implode and all of that but
essentially you have a magnet that
deflects
this electron beam and does it really
fast so it scans your entire screen of
different intensities and that's what
forms the image i won't go into that
detail maybe one day i'll do a whole
video on how tvs work so that's one
application of a magnetic field causing
a beam of charged particles to curve
and then the other application this is
actually one where it's actually useful
to make the particle go in a circle is
these cyclotrons that you read about
where they take these protons and they
make them go in circles really really
fast and then they smash them together
well have you ever wondered how do they
even make a proton go in a circle it's
not like you can hold it and you know
guide it around a circle well that's
what they do they pass it through an
appropriate
uh a
strength magnetic field and it curves
the path of the protons so they can keep
going through the same field over and
over again and and then they can use
those you know then they can actually
use
electric fields i don't know i don't
claim to have any expertise in this but
then they can keep speeding it up using
the same devices because it keeps
passing through the same part of the uh
through the of the of the of the
collider and once it collides you're
probably seeing those pictures
those pictures
right you know you spent billions of
dollars on super colliders and you end
up with these pictures and somehow these
physicists are able to take these
pictures and say oh this is some new
particle because of the way it moved
well actually what they're actually
talking about is you know these are
moving at relativistic speeds and since
they're at relativistic speeds as they
move
at different velocities their masses
change and all of that but the basic
the basic idea is what we just learned
they move in circles they move in
circles because they're going through a
magnetic field but they go they their
radiuses are different because their
charges and their velocities are going
to be different and and actually some
will move to the you know left some will
move to the right and that might be
because because they're positive or
negative or you know and then the radius
will be dependent on their masses anyway
i don't want to confuse you but i just
want to show you that we actually are
touching on some physics that a
physicist would actually care about
now with that said what would have
happened what would have happened if
this wasn't a proton but if this was an
electron moving at this velocity at 6
times 10 to the 7th meters per second
through a 0.5 tesla magnetic field
popping out of this video what would
have happened
well this formula would have still been
saying the magnet magnitude of the force
is the charge but it wouldn't be the
charge of the proton would be the charge
of an electron times 6 times 10 to the
seventh meters per second times 0.5
teslas so what's the difference between
the charge of a proton and a charge of
electron
well the charge of an electron is
negative so if this was an electron then
the net force would actually end up
being a negative number
so what does that mean
well when we use the right hand rule
with the proton example we said that the
at least when the pro when the proton is
moving in this direction that the net
force would be downwards right
but now all of a sudden if we reverse
the charge if we say we have a negative
charge it's the same magnitude but it's
negative because it's an electron what
happens where now the force is now in
this direction using the right hand rule
but it is negative so really it's going
to be a positive force of the same
magnitude in this direction
so if we have a proton it'll go a circle
in this direction it'll go like this
but if we have an electron it'll go in a
circle of the other direction
now let me ask you a question is that
circle going to be a tighter circle or a
or a wider circle
well the mass of an electron is a lot
smaller than the mass of a proton and we
have the radius is equal to the mass
times the velocity squared divided by
the centripetal force so if this mass is
smaller the radius is going to be
smaller so the electrons path would
actually it would move up
and it would be a smaller radius
actually proportional to the difference
the differences in the radiuses are is
the the difference in their masses
actually
but that would be the path of the
electron anyway i thought you'd be
interested in that as well
i have run out of time i will see you in
the next video